Una recta tiene una pendiente de
7 y pasa por el punto -4, -11.
¿Cuál es la ecuación de esta recta en la
forma pendiente-ordenada al origen?
Y bueno, la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen
es la siguiente,
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b",
donde "m" es la pendiente,
mientras que "b" es donde intersectamos
al eje de las yes,
es decir, mi ordenada al origen.
Y bueno, lo que ya nos dicen,
es que tenemos una pendiente de 7, por lo tanto,
"m" vale 7 y entonces yo puedo modificar esta función que tenemos aquí arriba,
sustituyendo a "m" por el valor de 7
y ¿qué me va a quedar?
"y" es igual a "m", pero en este caso "m" vale 7,
que multiplica a "x" más "b"....
Y déjame hacer una "x" más clara...
"7x" más "b".
Y bueno, no es toda la información
que me da el problema.
Además, el problema me da otra pista,
me dice que pasamos por el punto -4, -11.
Esto nos quiere decir que cuando "x" vale -4,
entonces "y" vale -11...
entonces "y" vale -11, es decir, cuando
"x" en esta ecuación que tenemos aquí, vale -4...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
"x" vale -4...
entonces en esa ocasión "y" vale -11.
Y esto nos da pie a que nos preguntemos,
¿cuál es la "b" que nos hace
que se cumpla esta igualdad?
Es decir, -11 es igual a 7...
déjame ponerlo así... -11 es igual a 7,
por "x" que vale -4 en ese punto, más "b".
Una "b" tal, que satisfaga, que cuando "x" valga -4, entonces "y" tenga que valer -11.
Y bueno, de aquí lo único que hay que hacer
es despejar a "b".
Y me queda que -11 es igual a 7 por -4,
que es -28, más "b".
Y bueno, si de aquí agrego 28 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
entonces
¿qué me va a quedar?
Déjame escribirlo... más 28 de este lado
y más 28 también de este lado.
Del lado izquierdo de la ecuación me queda -11 más 28, lo cual me da 17.
Y del lado derecho de la ecuación estos dos se van
y simple y sencillamente me queda "b".
Por lo tanto, déjame escribirlo por aquí,
que "b" vale 17 de color verde...
de color verde... no de color amarillo...
creo que el día de hoy se me están
yendo los colores.
"b" es igual a 17.
Y bueno, una vez que ya tengo a "b" entonces
puedo reescribir esta ecuación que yo tengo aquí,
sustituyendo el valor de "b".
Y me queda que "y" es igual
a la pendiente que era 7,
es decir, "y" es igual a "7x" más "b",
pero "b" ya sé que vale 17,
entonces más 17,
"y" es igual a "7x" más 17 y ya está.
Esta es mi ecuación de mi recta,
que por cierto podemos graficar.
Si éste es mi eje de las "x" y éste es mi eje de las yes, aquí tengo mi plano cartesiano,
yo sé que corta, mi recta, al eje de las yes
en el punto 0, 17,
por eso es muy importante "b",
aquí estamos en el punto 0, 17,
lo único que podemos hacer es sustituir aquí
y ver que cuando "x"vale 0, "y"vale 17
y además tenemos una pendiente de 7,
es decir, es una pendiente creciente.
Cuando "x" aumenta en 1, "y" aumenta en 7.
Cuando "x"disminuye en 1, "y" disminuye en 7.
Y ya tenemos estos puntos y por lo tanto,
ahora podemos graficar nuestra recta también.
Pero lo que sí sé, es que tiene una
pendiente bastante grande y positiva,
por lo tanto mi recta es creciente y además,
que nosotros sabemos que cuando
"x" vale 0, "y" vale 17,
es decir, que pasamos por este punto de aquí.